[Music]
today
we're back with another round of your
questions we've got questions about
microbes questions about how james our
master of microscopes
takes care of microbes and questions
about how we make these videos
some of these things we've seen come up
frequently in comments and
others are questions sent in via twitter
patreon and instagram
so thank you to everyone who's been
commenting and asking questions
we couldn't do any of this without your
shared excitement for all things
microcosmos
and every one of your comments and
questions
steers this channel on our journey
[Music]
question number one we've been asked if
there are any species of fungi
that live in the aqueous environment and
yes
there are we featured some in our recent
episode about
nematode trapping fungi which are very
fascinating
and also a teensy bit creepy there are
also other fungal parasites these amoeba
are infected with amoebophyllus simplex
a fungus that attacks certain amoeba and
then grow
spores out of them these euglenids are
also infected with
some kind of fungus though i couldn't
tell you which kind
moving out of the water and onto land
we've got a question about whether we've
had the chance to observe
modal soil microbes and whether we've
been able to look at species that come
from more than one mile down in the
ground
we've talked a bit about soil microbes
but the fact is
that the soil has an incredible
diversity of life in it
and we've barely scratched the surface
literally
and we'd love to dig deeper so that we
can see some of the organisms that live
a mile or more underground but we cannot
do that ourselves
so james has been trying to get a hold
of some samples from drilling companies
so fingers crossed on that next question
do organisms like gastrotrick have
gut flora they almost certainly
do have gut flora bacteria
are basically everywhere including in
the guts
of microscopic animals as for their role
in gastrotricks it could be
anything our own microbiome is made up
of bacteria
that do everything from help us digest
food
to manage our immune system and nature
is full of many incredible examples of
how gut flora and other
forms of microbiome inform the lives of
animals
so there's probably something cool going
on there
but no scientists as far as we know have
yet
investigated it
one of the most common questions we get
is how to start
your own journey to the micro cosmos
the easiest thing is to get some water
from outside
and look at it under a microscope but of
course
picking and purchasing a microscope can
be overwhelming
like any hobby it's probably best to
start off simple
and see what works for you get some
experience and then build from there
also we might be working
on some things to help you narrow down
your search
in the future but we can't talk about it
yet
of course microscopes are only one part
of the micro cosmos
experience the other big thing are the
microbes that you're going to look at
with them
and we've gotten a few questions about
how to best take care
of our invisible friends for the long
term
the key is to try to get samples that
are on the larger size
having a larger sample will make any
environmental changes
happen slower it's like the difference
between leaving a bottle of water out in
the sun versus a whole pool of water the
bottle
will get warmer faster now obviously
you're
not going to be gathering a whole pool's
worth of microbes
but in general it's best to air on the
side of larger samples
so that you can provide your microbes
with a study environment
in addition you'll also want to try and
mimic as much of their
original environment as possible so
collect leaves
sediment and aquatic plants from
wherever you're sampling
to make your microbes feel at home
we also get a ton of questions about how
to identify microbes
we've made an episode about just this
very thing but the crux of the whole
discussion
is that it's really a thing built on a
lot
of internet sleuthing and practice
but with that said our very own james
weiss will be publishing a book next
year
called the hidden beauty of the
microscopic world
to be published by penguin random house
which will be a picture-heavy book
that might help you with your
identification needs
which is very exciting congratulations
james
moving on to a microscope question what
is the minimum magnification needed to
see
single-celled organisms well
there are actually some single-celled
organisms large enough to be seen
without a microscope especially if you
put them in front of a strong
light like this stenter culture when it
comes to using a microscope we've been
able to use a magnification as low as
40x to see our samples
now it's time to get into some
behind-the-scenes
stuff several of you have been asking
about whether there are any microbes
that we want to
show but cannot for some reason
and yes definitely right now
we're hoping to find a super rare
ciliate called thyssana morpha
which has weird retractable tentacles
we'd love to feature archaea which are
single-celled prokaryotes distinct from
bacteria
but archaea are super tiny
even by microcosmos standards
archaeans are famed for their ability to
survive
in some of the hottest and saltiest
places on the planet
making them what we call extremophiles
and we
really really want to be able to talk
more about extremophiles
because it's incredible to learn more
about how microbes are able to survive
in some of the harshest environments
unfortunately
we don't know how to do that yet we
don't
know how to take care of them or capture
them on video and that
is on our wish list we also got a
question wanting to know whether james
has discovered something that's not just
new to him but new to science
and it turns out he has he found this
new ciliate a few months ago and
couldn't identify it
so he contacted some scientists working
on this group of organisms
there are reports of similar species
from the 1930s
but so far no description matches what
he's found
so james is working on trying to culture
them
and maybe do some genomic analysis and
hopefully
he'll get to write a paper and name the
organism
if he gets to do that we might even ask
you all
to pitch in some ideas someone else
asked whether we
worry about getting sick from some of
the things we're working with
which is always a good question to ask
because safety is an important thing to
keep track of
when you've got hundreds of containers
full of microbes in your home
so james exercises caution by not
handling the containers with an open
wound
he also washes his hands after working
with the microscope
the real challenge is making sure his
cats are staying safe because
cats in other cats so he's trained them
to avoid his samples by
blowing puffs of air on their face when
they try to climb up on his table
and his windowsills these are the little
bits of insight you get when you watch
the questions videos
on to some more nitty-gritty after we're
done observing the organism on the slide
what do we do with them do we dispose of
them or culture them
we don't really try to culture
everything but instead
we try to create little copies of the
environment that the organisms came from
so when we're done checking a slide
everything either gets washed back into
the sample container or
into a pond aquarium but if we do want
to culture them
james uses a micro pipette to select the
cells
one by one and transfer them to a clean
water drop
he'll repeat this a few times to wash
the cells
and then put them into some water to
culture
we get a lot of wonderful comments from
you all about the music on this channel
you've also asked about how it's
composed
the music is made by the very talented
andrew huang
you can find on youtube link in the
description and he said the following
quote the music for microcosmos is some
of the most
organic composing i've ever done where i
generally just
set out to explore a mood as suggested
by the team
or based on my own viewing of the series
i think he did a really wonderful job
this question is from andrew taylor who
asked on youtube
what motivated you to create this
channel
why did you branch out into the more
relaxing narrative
instead of continuing the high energy of
your other productions
and hey this is actually a question for
me
neat well at first i was motivated to
make the channel
after seeing some of james's videos on
youtube and i reached out and i was like
we should talk about these things but in
terms of
the vibe when you're making something
what it's going to
feel like how it's going to be
experienced that can't just come down to
like
what you know how to do or what you're
good at or what's become
expected of you or even a particular
platform like youtube
it has to be about what's right for the
content
and when i first saw james's videos
there was a vibe already there
so we just sort of followed that vibe
it was also a moment when i personally
needed some opportunities
maybe to slow down a little bit
sometimes that has only
felt more necessary to me in the years
since we launched
so i was excited to make something a
little more
chill and finally from time to time we
received comments asking us
about money maybe asking about our
patreon or sponsorships or youtube ad
revenue but the questions mostly boil
down
to a curiosity about how the finances of
a youtube channel work
and i love talking about that stuff
journey to the microcosmos is produced
by a larger company complexly
that makes scishow and crash course in
eons and about a dozen other youtube
channels
and when we launch something new at that
company we invest
money that we made from other things to
try
something in the hopes that the new
thing will become
self-sustaining it will gain an audience
it will gain support
and it will be able to continue to exist
when those things aren't able to sustain
their costs
that's when a show gets cancelled we
can't make shows that cost more money to
produce
than they make so what do we spend the
money on
several things our writer debokey on
mats editing and graphics and production
on andrew's music
and of course helping james continue his
amazing work
the one thing about this that is free is
the narration
which i guess i throw in because i'm the
ceo of complexly and i just really like
to work on this show the good news is
that because
this channel has the support of our
patreon patrons and advertisers
it's now making enough money that we can
think not just about
how to survive but also about how to
keep making
our content better now a lot of these
things are expensive but particularly
with microscopy
the smallest microscope parts can cost
thousands of dollars
but thanks to your support we've been
able to upgrade to a 4k
camera to produce even better looking
footage and
recently james was able to get a brand
new microscope
so that we can share the amazingness
that is dic microscopy
our next goal is to hit five thousand
dollars a month on patreon and that's
going to let us buy a 40x objective
for the new microscope similar to the
one we've used in the past for our
brightfield and darkfield clips
that way we can still get the stunning
footage we get with dic microscopy
but also get a more zoomed out view of
the micro cosmos
so if you're interested in joining our
amazing group of patrons
you can head over to patreon.com
journey2micro and together
we can change our perspective on the
world
and if you can't join our patreon all of
your support and views
comments likes and questions helps us
figure out
where to take our journey next so thank
you
for coming on this journey with us as we
explore the unseen world that surrounds
us
and again thank you to our patreon
patrons
all of these people here who yes as i
have just said
are the reason that the show can
continue to exist
so if you are thankful for this show
these
are the people you need to thank if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes
james weiss check out jam and germs on
instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you